il est l'heure de passer à la chronique
de l'éco bonsoir clair bonsoir on va
s'intéresser aux prêts solidaires ce
soir exactement depuis quelques années
des plateformes se sont créés sur
internet pour aider des porteurs de
projets à se financer donc les donateurs
sont des particuliers on compte parmi
ses sites kisskissbankbank notamment les
fondateurs de ce site est ouvert le 23
avril dernier une nouvelle plateforme
lots merci alors cette fois pas de dons
mais des prêts donc les porteurs de
projets devront rembourser la somme le
but de permettre à l'aboutissement de
projets personnels mais surtout
entrepreneuriaux au début on comptait
parmi les projets plus d'un tiers de
projets yvelinois alors pour en parler
nous recevons sur ce plateau vincent
ricordeau bonsoir bonsoir cofondateur du
site et le merci laurent tu vignon
bonsoir vous avez réussi à récolter via
ce site des prêts à hauteur de 3000
euros tout le monde et olivier 100 ch et
qui est chargé de mission au parc
régional de lorraine chevreuse
partenaires du site et on verra donc
pourquoi y ait eu autant de projets
évinois alors vincent ricordeau tout
d'abord qu'est-ce que les lots merci
quel est son concept et le merci c'est
une plate forme de prêt entre
particuliers où on va favoriser les
échanges d'argent entre les gens
directement sur les intermédiaires
classique pour qu'on puisse résoudre
entre nous nos soucis de trésorerie que
ce soit des problèmes de trait aux
persos ou de près de 13 ou
d'entrepreneurs alors les personnes en
fête propose en projet donc pendant 90
jours je pense tout à fait vous arrivez
sur la plateforme vous décrivez votre
projet vous choisissez l'objectif dont
vous avez besoin en euros donc servat de
200 jusqu'à 15000 euros et ensuite le
nombre de jours dont vous aurez besoin
pour collecter l'argent qui va durer 1
90 puis vu fixer tout simplement la
durée du remboursement soit si ronald ce
soir 18 fois sur 24 assure 36 mois il
faut arriver au montant final pour
récolter obligatoire dans c'est ce qu'on
appelle la règle du tout au rien c'est à
dire que vous avez que deux options soit
vous atteignez votre objectif et du cou
ou transfèrent l'argent collecté - la
commission des lots merci soit vous avez
loupé votre objectif et on rembourse
gratuitement et sans frais tous les
internautes alors vous aviez déjà
kisskissbankbank donc avec des dons
pourquoi avoir voulu finalement
développé une autre plateforme avec des
prêts cette fois c'est sur kiss kiss
aujourd'hui on a collecté plus de 6
millions d'euros on a reçu douze mille
projets il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
projets qui correspondent pas aux
critères de kiss kiss bang bang dédié en
fait à l'art la culture la rénovation du
cou à force de recevoir des projets
qu'on pouvait pas gérer on s'est dit
qu'il fallait trouver une solution en
l'occurrence pour ses points de vue ces
créations d'entreprises oui création
entreprises ou projets persos purement
qui rentrent pas dans les cases est
clairement quand on a un projet perso un
projet entrepreneurial
bien souvent la logique du don ne
fonctionne pas parce qu'on n'a pas grand
chose à donner en échange de vraiment
émotionnelles et que la logique du prêt
se prêtent beaucoup mieux à ce mécanisme
là d'où la création de l'eau merci
olivier sange vous êtes chargé de
mission au parc de la vallée de
chevreuse pourquoi le parc s'est il
retrouvé partenaires alors pourquoi pas
tout simplement moi je travaille
effectivement je suis chargé de mission
développement économique au parc de la
vallée de chevreuse et particulièrement
dans notre mission au niveau du parc on
accompagne les projets de développement
local création d'activités commerces
services et évidemment on aide les
porteurs de projets dans ce cadre à
monter des plans de financement donc on
est parfois confronté à des problèmes de
plan de financement des recherches de
budget et
on trouve l idée de kiss kiss bang bang
d'ouvrir donc un nouveau système une
plateforme lots merci avec un système de
prêt dirigé sur le développement local
très intéressante vous avez été mis en
contact finalement avant la création du
site ce qui a permis d'alimenter en
projet oui on a eu la chance
effectivement d'être mis en contact
avant la création du site via vient
notre rue un autre réseau qui s'appelle
la ruche qui dit oui et on a donc du
coup pu participer effectivement avec un
des co fondateurs de la plateforme à
réfléchir aux interfaces dont ont besoin
les porteurs de projets pour décrire
leur projet communiquer dessus expliqué
le but de leur collecte leur divine yong
c1 par olivier sens que vous avez été
amené à postuler nous sur sur ce site
pourquoi cherchez-vous des financements
bannu avec un collet qui s'appelle alain
pelosse on développe à partir d'une
activité qui est déjà existantes sur les
étourneaux hollande en forêt de
rambouillet
une entreprise de location de vélos
d'encadrement de balades dans la vallée
de chevreuse ou en ile-de-france aussi
mais particulièrement ici en vallée de
chevreuse et il se trouve que au delà la
location on a d un projet de
développement de cette activité sur des
choses qui vont de la lazio de la
location qui sont plutôt des choses
autour d'écomobilité ce que le parc est
un projet là dessus notamment et un
moment donné donc on a cherché comme
tout entrepreneur un peu d'argent pour
démarrer pour continuer en tous les cas
et c'est à ce moment là que je me suis
fait connaître moi comme tout
entrepreneur en étant sur le parcours au
service économique du parc que je
connaissais par ailleurs mais on s'est
fait connaître sur le projet et puis de
fil en aiguille d'ailleurs ça s'est fait
très vite à l'époque
rencontre avec vincent téléphoniques et
et puis on a commencé je dirai pas ce
que c'est un peu ça quand même quand on
est entrepreneur à bricoler le modèle le
mécanisme comme disait vincent de ce
prêt vous cache pas qu'au début j'étais
un peu british gt pas être totalement à
l'aise dans tous les cas avec ça moi
j'ai l'habitude de plutôt aller voir les
banques et manipuler un peu plus
d'argent sur des grosses sommes avec les
banques les fondations
circuit
générant des circuits classiques pour
moi je viens des circuits courts vous
avez du maraîchage biologique déjà le
circuit court ça me plaisait bien et
alors déjà la première raison c'est que
olivier sens je m'obligeais donc ça faut
quand même le dire mais il a eu raison
et puis la deuxième raison c'est que
comme je disais que j'étais un peu
réticent c'est qu'à un moment donné j'ai
aussi vu en tant qu'entrepreneur pas
seulement l'aspect financier parce que
3000 euros pour nous c'est important on
voit jeu pour en donner des exemples de
tout à l'heure de ce qu'on en fait
concrètement aujourd'hui mais il ya
aussi un aspect de promotion en fait
c'est comme l'a rappelé vincent tout à
l'heure l'enjeu c'est de réussir certes
c'est un peu le tout ou rien donc déjà
ya un côté un peu de challenge qui nous
plaît bien et puis aller au bout
alors ça permet déjà de faire se
connaître on a eu pas mal de médias
derrière depuis deux ou trois mois là
qui nous ont appelés tout simplement
parce qu'on avait réussi et puis
effectivement ça permet d'aller voir le
banquier de manière un peu plus sereine
quoi alors avant de poursuivre je vous
propose d'aller à la rencontre de deux
autres porteurs de projets yvelinois qui
ont cherché des financements via hi lo
merci un reportage mené par elodie
l'occar mélodies l'occar pardon la
finance solidaire envahi le département
une nouvelle plate forme de prêt entre
particuliers atteint 0 a vu le jour en
avril dernier sur la vingtaine de
projets présentés au lancement 6 situés
autour du parc naturel régional de la
vallée de chevreuse
patricia l'ami elle rêve de créer sa
ferme du ciel une sorte de un rap au
monde half year qui accueillerait
visiteurs d'un jour et passionné de
ballon dans des chambres d'hôtes une
première européenne chiffré à 1 million
d'euros qui seraient financés en partie
par le prêt solidaire moi j'ai demandé
douze mille euros ce qui effectivement
est peut-être un peu beaucoup pour une
vague forme comme l eau merci sur hello
merci les porteurs de projets peuvent
demander entre 200 et 15000 euros ils
déterminent eux-mêmes une durée de
remboursement comprise entre 1 et 36
mois j'ai trouvé que c'était un bon
moyen pas seulement d'avoir de l'argent
mais de faire connaître le projet à tous
mes proches et c'est vrai que c'est
presque plus important finalement sacrés
des relations des gens des cousins que
je n'avais plus vu depuis des années se
sont rapprochés de moi donc on
recommence à se voir ils m'ont prêté un
petit peu d'argent c'est vraiment pas
beaucoup mais ce qui est drôle c'est que
du coup on a retrouvé des relations avec
de la famille éloignée ou des amis qu'on
avait perdu de vue pour l'instant la
pilote n'a récolté que deux mille cinq
cent cinquante euros un décollage un peu
timide mais de l'autre côté de la vallée
de chevreuse dans son laboratoire au
fond de son jardin laurence ghali a eu
plus de chance en neuf jours elle a
réussi à récolter 5000 euros un budget
pour imprimer ces nouvelles boîtes et
ainsi vendre ses savons biologique en
boutique 5000 euros qu'elle s'engage à
rembourser sur l'honneur c'est une
plateforme internet tout le monde ya
accès donc il ya une visibilité du fait
que vous remboursez ou pas vos prêteurs
voilà par rapport à l'image et par
rapport à la notoriété de l'entreprise
il ya un impact direct et réel concret
qui intervient et puis c'est moi dans
mon cas c'est des amis c'est vraiment
mon cercle premier qui m'a prêté donc
évidemment je vais faire tout ce qu'il
faut pour que pour que le prêt soit
rembourser
les dettes sont en effet contracté entre
le prêteur et le porteur de projet le
site est le merci n'a aucune
responsabilité juridique c'est donc un
prêt risques et non pas à un retour sur
investissement mais plutôt à fort
capital émotionnel c'est un moyen aussi
pour nous en étant en dehors de la
création d'entreprise d'avoir ce
sentiment de participer d'aider un
projet d'aider à son développement aussi
et puis surtout à une action locale la
valorisation du territoire local c'est
aussi la spécificité de cette nouvelle
plateforme le concept lui avaient été
importés en france notamment par
babylone en 2008 en 2012 la finance
solidaire avait récolté plus d'un
milliard d'euros
alors pour information patricia lamy n'a
finalement pas réussi à récolter la
somme des 12000 euros alors vincent la
gare d'eau déjà quel pourcentage un
petit peu de réussite sur le site
on s'arrête au pourcentage qu'on a
aujourd'hui les ultras bluffant il ya
douze projets sur les 14 premiers qui
ont réussi à collecter de l'argent donc
du coup on serait près de 90 % et en
l'occurrence ce sera pas le pourcentage
et au final on sera je pense vers un
pourcentage de 50-60 pensants les
premiers ont bénéficié tout le buzz du
lancement de la plateforme très encadrés
par des partenaires du coup le
pourcentage d un peu sûre qu'on y est
mais dans les mêmes eaux qui skie le
moment je pense qu'un peu plus d'un
projet sur 2 arrivera collecter s'ils
voulaient à terme est ce que finalement
le la somme aussi les 12000 euros c'est
quand même assez important on peut aller
jusqu'à 15000 ce qu'il faut finalement
pas être trop gourmand en fait il faut
arriver à calibrer le montant de
l'emprunt par rapport à la force des
communautés qui vous suivent tout
simplement et c'est vrai que c'est plus
une logique d'analysé de cartographie de
communauté que d'un réel besoin qu'il
faut mener pour arriver à tomber sur le
bon objectif mais c'est en l'occurrence
on a une équipe qui est très entraînés à
ça et on coach nous tous les projets
pour essayer de déterminer au plus près
l'objectif qui se réalise c'est
finalement pour ça marche il ya les amis
les proches un peu plus éloignés et
c'est ça qui m'a fait revenir d'autres
oui la magie du profane inglés les 3
milliards 4 milliards bientôt 100
milliards dont on parle sur les
plateformes mondiales sur le
crowdfunding marche tout de la même
façon quand kraft foods ou quand vous
financez d'argent sur la plateforme vous
adresser d'abord votre premier cercle la
magie notre plateforme c'est qu'elle vit
réalise vos projets sur les réseaux
sociaux et également dans la vraie vie
tout ça crée un deuxième cercle et puis
ensuite avec le buzz globale ça m'a
souvent touché des inconnus et du coup
vous allez passer du premier cercle au
deuxième et potentiellement troisième
qui vous permet de dupliquer en fêtes
loto communauté d'origine mais par
contre si la communauté d'origine ne sut
pas n'est ce pas serait laurenti vignon
vous même vous demander 3000 euros
c'était une petite partie 2 et
finalement de votre demande de
financement votre besoin de financement
est ce qui vous a étonné c'est que vous
avez eu aussi des inconnus qui ont qui
vous ont aidé oui pour donner des
repères trois mille euros c'est grosso
modo 15 à 20 pourtant notre financement
pour l'année 2013-2014 on va dire en
termes de de lancement du projet
d'amorçage sur cèze prêteurs il y en a
dix que je connais si ce que je ne
connais pas ou alors si je les connais
je me souviens plus et pour l'anecdote
faut arriver à 3000 pile donc en fait il
ya un dernier prêteurs que ne connaît
pas qui a prêté 95 euros c'est ce qui
manquait et tout d'un coup vous lever un
matin vous allez sur la plate forme
parce que forcément vous y aller tous
les jours voire plusieurs fois par jour
et du coup vous arrivez à 3000 et là ça
fait plaisir et effectivement on a donc
là 40 % de personnes que je ne connais
pas alors dans le reportage ce qui était
indiqué c'est que la finance solidaire a
récolté 1 milliards d'euros en 2012 ça
reste un chiffre impressionnant les
visages est ce que vous vous étiez
persuadé finalement que les gens
suivrait et oui complètement connaissant
déjà un peu le monde du chrono funding
effectivement je pensais qu'il y avait
un excellent potentiel et un manque
justement pour les projets de
développement économique puisque comme
l'a dit vincent on était plutôt
auparavant sur des dispositifs
culturel artistique et on a en plus en
effet au niveau de nos actions de
communication une demande également des
habitants dans les villages où on a les
projets ou des élus pour relayer
l'information pour faire participer la
population donc oui il ya vraiment un
facteur de réussite intéressant